from Tropical Islands to dystopian
wastelands to the farthest reaches of
the universe here's where you've seen
the cast members of Amazon's music
mockumentary Daisy Jones and the six
before
Daisy Jones lead Riley Keough has music
in her blood she's the granddaughter of
king of rock and roll Elvis Presley as
well as the daughter of Lisa Marie
Presley and Danny Keough both musicians
in their own right Riley Keough is also
no stranger to musical dramas as her
first on-screen role was the 2010 biopic
The Runaways in which he played Marie
Curie more big screen features followed
including Mad Max Fury Road the crime
keeper Logan lucky the psychological
horror flicked the launch and the a24
black comedy Zola as for TV in 2016 Keo
was the lead on season one of the star's
Anthology drama the girlfriend
experience an adaptation of the 2009
Steven Soderbergh drama starring a
former adult film star Sasha Gray Kyo
took another leading TV role in 2022
this time on the Amazon Thriller the
terminal list
the band at the center of Daisy Jones
and the six is led by Billy Dunn who's
played by English actor Sam Claflin he's
probably best known for his turns as
Finnick in The Hunger Games series he
previously made his big screen debut
back in 2011 as Philip Swift the young
missionary captured by Blackbeard and
Pirates of the Caribbean on Stranger
Tides sticking with the franchise work
Claflin also played William in Snow
White and the Huntsman and its sequel
his other notable cinematic credits
include the survival drama adrift and
the romance flicks me before you and
love wedding repeat more recently he
started Netflix's anola homes in which
he assumed the iconic role of Mycroft
the eldest Holmes sibling and over on
the small screen from 2019 to 2022
Claflin was a regular cast member on the
British crime drama peaky blinders as
real-life politician sir Oswald Mosley
we deal in reason principle argument and
fact
[Applause]
former model Camilla Marone stars on
Daisy Jones as Camilla Dunn wife of band
leader Billy if you know her name but
not her work it's probably because of
her controversial relationship with
Leonardo DiCaprio which ended shortly
after she turned 25. Marone hasn't
starred in anything huge yet but she has
shown up in a few notable movies in 2018
she was one of the leads in the Indie
Stoner comedy never going back and she
played the daughter of Bruce Willis's
vigilante character in the remake of
Death Wish and in 2020 she showed up in
valley girl a remake of the 1983
Nicholas Cage film of the same name with
a leading role on Daisy Jones Marone is
putting her modeling work behind her as
she focuses instead on her budding
Hollywood career as she told the Wall
Street Journal in 2020 I think it's hard
for the world and also the industry to
be able to see you as both
model turned actress Suki Waterhouse
stars in Daisy Jones and the six as
keyboardist Karen a headstrong musician
determined to break the mold of women in
Show Business she's yet to have a true
breakout role but she has appeared in
plenty of notable films including the
2014 romantic dramedy Love Rosie which
also featured Sam Claflin she also
played Kitty Bennett in 2016's Pride and
Prejudice and Zombies Waterhouse finally
secured a leading role in the bad batch
in which she fought off a gang of
deranged cannibals in a dystopian future
and then in 2019 she could be seen in
detective Pikachu as Ms Norman the
genetically modified ditto and in the
2021 indie horror flick seance it's been
a long time in the making so we're I
think we're ready I love it
while several actors from Daisy Jones
started out as models nabia B's first
career makes her even more suited for a
musical drama she stars as Simone
Jackson best friend to Daisy Jones
though B's career in Hollywood has
barely begun it's her life as a
singer-songwriter and Broadway actress
that proves her bonafides B has thus far
appeared in just one feature film but
it's one of the biggest of all time as
she had a small role in 2018's superhero
epic black panther she played Linda
Johnson a highly trained Black Ops
Soldier and girlfriend of the villainous
Eric killmonger hailing from Brazil B
has received accolades for her stage
work including the Drama Desk award for
her performance in school girls or the
African Mean Girls play She also played
the role of eurydice in the Off-Broadway
version of the Tony winning Broadway
musical Hades Town Daisy Jones is her
first major TV role as she plays a disco
star who mentors the title character
among the relative newcomers of the
daisy Jones cast is Will Harrison an
Ithaca native who spent most of his
young adult life in Massachusetts before
attending Carnegie Mellon school of
drama in 2019 at the age of 22 Harrison
appeared on an episode of the CBS
political drama Madam Secretary a year
later he starred in the Indie drama this
is a film about my mother on Daisy Jones
he plays Graham Dunn younger brother of
Billy and the group's lead guitarist and
co-founder It's a larger and meteor role
than Harrison has ever played thus far
in his career he stands to gain serious
attention from the series as a strong
performance could Spotlight his talent
on a larger stage and result in his big
break hi that's the story that I had
heard yet
Sebastian Chacon may have one of the
biggest bodies of work among the
lesser-known daisy Jones cast members as
he's shown up in some of today's biggest
TV hits he started his Hollywood career
with a small part on an episode of
Madam's secretary before moving on to
the USA techno Thriller Mr Robot from
there he showed up for a single episode
on a bunch of other shows in a wide
range of genres including the Batman
prequel Gotham and cbs's Sherlock Holmes
series Elementary chicon eventually
began snagging recurring roles including
two episodes of pose a three-story stint
on tales of the city and finally the
part of fly Rico on Penny Dreadful City
of Angels and as for the big screen he
had a key role in the 2022 Indie
Thriller emergency now that he's a
series regular on a hotly anticipated
show he can finally call himself a star
in the role of guitarist Eddie Roundtree
is a little-known British actor Josh
Whitehouse who boasts a modest but
impressive resume if you've seen him
before it was likely on the BBC
historical drama series poldark on which
he was a main cast member for seasons 3
and 4. the 2020 remake of valley girl
was a starring vehicle for White House
as he played Randy the 80s punk rocker
who becomes the object of desire for a
Los Angeles teenage girl the previous
year he starred opposite Vanessa Hudgens
in the Netflix holiday Romance movie The
Night Before Christmas in which he
played a 14th century night transported
to the modern day
love is the first and foremost of all
nightly virtues in addition to Daisy
Jones White House is due to star in the
upcoming the happy worker as well as the
animated film Ozzy the voice of the
forest
Tom Wright plays Teddy price the
producer at the record company who first
brings Daisy Jones to the attention of
the six and sticks by their side as they
rise to the top of the charts a longtime
veteran character actor Wright is the
kind of face you know you've seen but
might have trouble placing starting his
career out in the early 80s it's
possible you know right as the titular
hitchhiker on the Creepshow 2 segment
The Hitchhiker you may also recognize
him from any number of 80s and 90s
favorites as he racked up credits in
plenty of movies from those decades
including Tales from the Hood as for TV
trekkies will no doubt remember him as
the ill-fated transporter creation that
was doomed to die on the Star Trek
Voyager episode 2 vix meanwhile sitcom
fans may remember him from four episodes
of Seinfeld as Mr Morgan the skeptical
Yankee Stadium co-worker of George
Costanza after appearances on a number
of hit dramas Wright became a series
regular on the BYU TV series Granite
Flats as FBI agent Ezekiel Scott more
recently he starred on the 2020 Netflix
sitcom medical police on which he played
CDC director Pat
there may be only one man more important
to Daisy Jones and the six of success
than producer Teddy price and that would
be manager Rod Reyes he's played by the
legendary Timothy Oliphant who's enjoyed
a career bringing to life Charming
Rogues and swaggering do-gooders he's
something of a modern day John Wayne as
he's best known for playing a couple of
iconic lawmen first there was U.S
Marshal Seth Bullock on the
groundbreaking HBO Western Deadwood that
led to his stirring turn as raylen
Givens the sharp shooting steely-eyed
gunslinging Marshall on fx's crime drama
Justified which is easily his most
iconic work to date Oliphant then showed
off his funny side beginning in 2017 on
the Netflix zombie sitcom Santa Clarita
diet alongside Drew Barrymore then he
returned to the role of a martial on
season 4 of the Anthology series Fargo
after playing himself on the sitcoms the
good place and the grinder he played a
marshall once again but this time in a
galaxy far far away on the Star Wars
Disney plus series The Mandalorian and
the Book of Boba Fett as for the movies
oliphan's most notable role include
James Stacy in 2019's Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood and Mickey and Scream 2 all
the way back in 1997. and he's set to
have a busy 2023 as he's due to return
to the role of Raelynn Givens for the
mini-series Justified City primeval
you might want to factor them items into
the equation before you decide what
you're going to do next
rhyme dramas you know
Dame or at least the phase of Jacqueline
oberdoors she has a recurring role on
Daisy Jones as Lucia but for the past
several decades she's been a small
screen stalwart including on a couple of
the most well-regarded crime dramas of
their day from 2001 to 2005 Obradors
played Detective Rita Ortiz on NYPD Blue
she appeared in 80 episodes of the
series which led to guest appearances on
plenty of other shows she eventually
landed another regular role this time as
another detective on the Amazon crime
procedural Bosch beginning with season
five though she's always been more of a
TV actor Obradors does have a few
notable movie roles on her resume fans
of the 2001 animated Disney sci-fi
Adventure Atlantis the Lost Empire May
recognize her as the voice of teenage
mechanic Audrey she also appeared in the
Wesley Snipes action thriller
Unstoppable in 2004 and in 1998's action
adventure comedy Six Days Seven Nights
another relative newcomer to Hollywood
Aisha Harris plays Bernie on Daisy Jones
which is her biggest part to date a
barber in her pre-acting days before she
left Long Beach California Harris made
her on-screen debut in 2017. when she
appeared on an episode of The CW horror
series two sentence horror stories while
Harris's role on Daisy Jones is a
potential turning point in her career
it's not as if she's never been on a hit
series she's mostly had minor blink and
you'll miss him roles but maybe in 2022
you noticed her when she made a delivery
on an episode of the ABC sitcom Abbott
Elementary she also made her big screen
debut that same year in the Anthology
film tell it like a woman which was
nominated for best original song at the
Oscars 2023 is shaping up to be an even
bigger year for Harris in addition to
playing Bernie she's also signed up for
the Netflix series glamorous on which
she'll appear alongside Kim Cattrall in
the story of a young gender
non-conforming queer person who gets a
gig working for a renowned makeup artist
[Music]
foreign